I
it's a big pleasure for me to introduce
Francis Galton fans ask is a an
experienced pie
developer with over 15 years of
experience in height on and
high-performance computing he's the
maintainer of tools such as no max and
the author of tools such as pie tables
and the blask high-performance
compressor and he'll be talking to you
today about data oriented programming
thank you so thank you very much
Valentin for the nice introduction so
good afternoon everybody so my talk I
would like to introduce you to the
wonderful world of data oriented
programming I mean that means that many
people when tries to get the best
performance of the program of the
programs they basically thinks in
throwing all the CPUs that they can find
around in order to solve the problem
faster in my top revolves about the idea
that throwing CPUs is not longer enough
and you need to heart to think hard
about how you use memory and when you
access memory efficiently so I will
start with a toy problem to motivate why
memory access is important then I will
explain much more in detail which is the
problem with the data access issue in
particular why modern CPUs are starving
why Cassius has been introduced in the
industry and then some techniques for a
fact in dicta starvation I when I will
finish with showing you some optimal
containers for big data so slight about
me I integrated well Valentin set of
tools like I tables loss because analog
maintainer of new mex which is a tool
for evaluating Moonpie expressions very
efficiently as we will see i am an
experienced developer and trainer in
python and also in particular in
high-performance computing and storage
and also i am also available for
consulting so
let's start with the motivation of the
problem and the thing that I will I will
try to demonstrate now is that cpu speed
is not long l not longer the holy grail
of performance so let's suppose that we
want to compute the next polynomial
there which is very very easy apparently
to compute the rate minus one to one
with and we want them in ten millions to
evaluate the millions of elements and
what we want is to do of course evaluate
this polynomial as fast as possible of
course they write the net approach that
you may think it's to use new pipe and
pies a very efficient library mostly
written in C with the rappers in in
Python of course to call the defendant
machinima from Python and well
evaluating that in dump I it takes like
around one dot six seconds in some
machine so we are interested in making
this evaluation faster okay so which
approach do you think that we can follow
for avoiding this faster what would you
what we would you do some yeah some idea
turn the hardest yes so yeah that's a
very good thing but probably people
doesn't think like you and maybe some
people may think that they want to
paralyze or straight ahead right so if
we have like four cores you know work
laptops nowadays why not using them okay
so let's suppose that we are doing this
this this this problem is of computing
the polynomial it's the typical example
of embarrassing bleep are eligible
example so it's just a matter of
dividing they know me the domain to
compute in n chunks and evaluate
expression for this change so that this
can be easily implemented in in python
by using the multi
Sumio module so that we can bypass the
gill effectively so by using two cores
for example this dot one dot 66 seconds
is reduced then down to one dot two
seconds approximately so this is a
thirty-four thirty-five percent of
improvement and we may say well that's
not too bad and perhaps we can think we
are done well perhaps not and for
example you have to GST tag would I
could approach so the pamir a better
approach is to try to optimize before to
try to paralyze so for example if we are
express this numbaa expression and we
write in the factorized version with
that execution time using numpy go from
one dot six seconds just to zero dot 3
so this is a this is much faster in fact
a four times faster than using two
processors by using the initial
multiprocessing approach so this is the
first takeaway message for today so do
not blindly try to paralyze right away
because normally optimizing normally
gives much better results and in fact a
serial code base is much it's normally
much easier to code and especially to
the back ok so don't be so another
facilities to use other libraries not
only optimizing so for example let's
suppose that we want to use new mex so
let's see what new mex can do for our
example no max is just in time compiler
which is based on unknown pi data
structures that optimized evaluation of
complex expressions so the usage is very
simple just replace the expressions and
put them between codes so basically pass
desperation as a string to new mex
evaluate ok and that's all that's the
way to new mex works and in this case
new mex they takes like zero dot 14
seconds to complete that means that it's
11 times faster than the original
Moonpie doing exactly evaluating exactly
the same expression with a factorization
ok of course no max is new mex all is
also a sensible to do optimizations and
in this case using the factorization of
the polynomial we can by using this this
is this this expression we can even
reduce more the time in this case is
zero lot 11 seconds which is three times
faster than equivalent the evaluating
the equivalent expression in Mumbai so
here we have a another view of the other
results in the on the left we can we
seen them we can see the times for the
non pi a new mex and we can see that in
this case is time numis can be tense
times faster and on the right side we
can see that new mex can be three times
faster everything it's using one single
core no max by default you see several
course but I said new mex in this case 2
1 cor just to compare to label to
compare peace peace with peers and
apples apples both with apples so here
we have a couple of questions so first
why new mex is so amazingly fast
compared with non pie with for the first
example and then in the second example
which is like a kind of an optimal
approach for the problem why no max it's
still faster than the need so anyone has
an answer for the first question why
what these huge difference on the left
of the of the plot ya know in this case
no maybe in the second case no okay
so basically what new mex does is it
fits tries to optimize expressions as
well it's not only using multiprocessing
and not using the memory efficiently but
also optimizing expressions okay so
basically what new mex is doing in this
case is converting the original
polynomial into the polynomial below
okay into the description below what's
the difference the difference between
both expressions basically that in the
second expression we are not using this
very spensive pole system call okay the
power means that is the way to ln to
power to compute the power of one
variable to another variable okay these
variables can be floating points in
general and evaluating this is very
expensive in general that takes like
maybe tens or even yeah several tens of
clock cycles to evaluate whereas the
second version only have multiplications
okay when multiplications in in modern
CPUs takes typically one clock cycle
which is very fast to evaluate okay even
less if pipelines and disappears works
well I mean for this case pipeline is
work it will work very well so this is
the the answer for the first difference
but for the second difference there is
no I there is no call to the pole as
system call okay and new mex is still
three times faster than mumbai ok so the
question is why is wrong and i think
somebody give the right answer let's
show the short answer is that mu max is
making a more efficient use of the
memory resource ok so just my by doing
that you can get three times motor speed
so the long answer is a little bit much
a little bit more involved so let me
splain introduce you to the starving CPU
problem in order to fully understand why
accessing memory is so important
nowadays
so this problem is that the problem is
that the CPUs noah day is typically stay
bored doing nothing most of the time so
and this is this is because typically
they are waiting for data so here is
devolution of of the memory speed the
memory access time throughout the time
starting in nineteen eighty-two until to
2007 and we can see that the evolution
of the speed of the CPUs is much faster
than the evolution of the speaking if
memory okay so this is because of
fundamental reasons basically due to the
to the power dissipation problems when
you try to access memory very fast and
then the interesting thing about this
plot is that this gap is opening and
there isn't there are no signs that this
this open this opening in the gap is
going to stop anytime soon so that in
fact creates a big bottleneck between
the CPU and the memory and people is not
just writing small articles about that
Google is writing entire books about the
problem and how you can try to make the
memory access much more efficient so for
example this book is I think the title
is very split it so its title the memory
system you can't avoid it you can't
ignore it and you can fake it okay so I
think this shows the problem may be
explicitly so this is the status of the
CPU starvation in today so memory
latencies much as lower between 100 and
probably 5 500 times than processor
which is a lot then we rebound with its
improving at a better rate that memory
latency but still is like it's lagging
behind processors a lot so it's so you
can bring information to the probe to
the CPU between 30 times and 100 times
slower than the CPU can could possibly
process which is also quite a lot so
this is exactly the reason why the
vendors started to traduce caches in the
CPUs okay so a CPU cache latency and
throughput are normally much better than
memory or ram memory however the faster
they run they must the smaller they must
be and this is because of dissipation
power dissipation problems okay you
cannot put just one gigabyte of cash in
you CPUs and make it run at the same as
Pete honest than the CPU because it
literally will explode the CPU will
explode so this is the CPU cache
evolution so at the end of the 80s the
architecture of of machines were very
simple was very simple so there was just
a cpu then the memory in the middle and
in mechanical disc and people had just
program for these kinds of architectures
nowadays we have much haggar hair keys
okay so we have typically three levels
of cache and CPUs we have the memory
layer well we have a new layer which is
called the solid state disk which can be
used to accelerate access to the
mechanical disc as well okay maybe
obviously it is not the same thing to
program efficiently and architecture
from the 80s then program efficiently on
architecture for anomalies okay this you
should have in mind this cache hierarchy
so we need to know how gaseous work in
order to make them efficient right so
cash is a defective mainly in to a
scenarios so the first one is when there
is time locality that means that when
the data set is reduced and the other
one is when there is a special locality
and that means that the data set is
accessed sequentially so let me explain
this with a little more of detail so for
example and support that we have a
memory and a/c array in memory
two-dimensional array
and we are accessing these four elements
there so the first time that we want to
access these elements these elements has
to be brought into the CPU into the cash
in this case okay the first time that we
have to transmit these elements it will
take a long time but the second time
that we want to access exactly the same
elements the elements are already in
cash okay so grabbing them from cash is
much more faster so this is the time
locality and then cash is also are also
effective when there is a spatial
locality and a special locality means
that when you are accessing the data
that is sequentially and that is to get
that is bound together what it is store
need near to each other you can get much
more much better performance okay so for
example in case of a CRA the layout of
the other storage is typically row row
row based so if you access your data
draw wise you will be getting much more
performance because the architecture
will bring data much faster it's
designed like that like that okay
whereas if you are access data on the
roll on a roll Weiss base or just in a
random and way you will not be taken
advantage of the spatial locality and
that will be and that will be very bad
for the performance of your programs so
a very simple way to take leverage of
these golf localities in 40 problem
making taking advantage of CPU caches is
the blocking technique so the blanket
technique is very simple one so it
basically says that when you are
accessing disk or memory you try you
will try it you have to try to get a
contiguous block that fits in CPU cache
it doesn't fit it doesn't make sense of
course then operate happening and they
use it as much as possible so typically
if you have a couple of data sets and
you want to operate
to complete some operations between the
data sets what the blocking technique is
taking that is that you need to divide
logically detector sets in blocks then
do the operations for every block okay
the blocks will be transmitted
automatically for you for the guy in the
cache then all the operations will be
done in the indicas complete linkage and
then the result will be copied back to
the final container and then the words
in red mean contiguous mean taking
advantage of the spatial locality and
reduced the data in the cache means take
advantage of temporal locality so this
isn't usually the blocking technique and
I think it's time now for answer
depending question so the question was
why no max was like three times faster
than then for developing this factorized
version of the polynomial when both
mumbai and new mex are made in pure see
especially for doing this this operation
so the answer is how both approach works
so the non pi approach for example for
evaluating a single expression like a a
multi-plate x b plus c is that it new
pack has to follow the Python convention
and it needs temporaries so it typically
uses a and B and complete the
multiplication and store that rain in
memory okay this is called a temporary
and then this temporary is used and
added to the co-parent in order to get
the final result so we have the the the
the the result of that is that we have
big temporary memory what is doing new
mex is applying the blocking technique
okay so we'll fetch it will divide
logical in the appearance in chunks it
will operate with with a junction in the
cash Darrell in the cash even the
temporaries will be will be stored in
the cache and then the final result will
be copied back to the final destination
so we are completely avoiding the
temporary is the big temporaries so this
just avoiding this temporaries is making
new mex three times faster in this case
the Mumbai so this is this is a I think
very clear example of why dealing with
memory is very important so this is the
second message for today so before
spending too much of the Machine by
yourself make you a favor and use try to
use the existing powerful libraries out
there okay it is pretty difficult to
beat performance professionals okay so
the last part of my oh my talk will be
will revolve around the concept of
trying to use not only the best
libraries for computing but also the
best libraries for containing your your
data so as I said before too many times
we're focused on competing as fast as
possible that we have seen how important
data accesses and hence there is having
the optimal data structure its structure
it's critical for getting good
performance when processing very large
especially when processing very large
data sets because it is where the memory
subsystem is stressed the most and we
hope we have to be aware of the fact
that there is no silver bullet and it
won't be in the next feature I mean
there is no data container that is meant
for all the cases and we have to be
aware of that okay so native nope i made
a panda's nether because no no data
container will be useful for all the all
the cases and we make over the mind to
make our mental to this fact so for
example numpy its de facto standard
vector container and in fact it allowed
they perish the parison of a very rich
ecosystem and around it and it is very
cool they tagged data container and
so a computer library it has many
advantages like it allowed for the
multidimensional storage it allows for
efficient data access for many scenarios
not everything of course and then
provides powerful weaponry for data
handling and also efficiently memory
storage but also only in memory of
course nothing is perfect and no pie
although it is great for many use cases
it also comes with its own deficiencies
so for example is not efficient for the
pending data I will show you that why so
so take the content is tend to be static
you cannot deal with compressed data
transparently and it has limited support
for data based date for this work for
this based data so let me explain why
moon pie is not very efficient for a
pending data so typically when when you
want to a large an Opia rail the new pie
array is contiguous okay so in order to
enlarge it you need to do a new malach
copy the old contents of the all-terrain
into the new into the new malach into
the new memory area and then they leave
that adobe append will be copied at the
end of the new malach area okay so as
you can see you are doing a copy
operation if you Lube i erase a large
you are incurring in a big cost for
doing that very big so for example are
you going to traduce you to be calls
which is a library that i am working in
order to overcome with some non pi
limitations and let me explain you the
basics of pickles so because it's a
columnar chant and compressed data
container for python it offered two
flavors for four containers one is
one is called CRA which is meant for
multi-dimensional storage it's very
close to N to the NT Array in New pie
and then there is see table which is
more meant for intelligence data
container it's more close to the rec to
the strata-ray in moon pie it implements
just a few simple but fast iterators on
top of the containers supporting also
query semantics and it uses the powerful
blast compressor on the under the hood
so let me explain why columnar is
interesting for especially for big data
sets interesting thing about columnar is
that when you are doing queries in these
large tables if your tables are stored
in a column wise way only the intrastate
data is accessed and that means less I
are required so let me show you when
it's an diagram showing home for example
this is an a table which is Anna memory
row-wise table so this is a typical
example of an oompa structured array
okay numpy that contains a heterogeneous
data so in case we want to access or to
do a query just in the second column
which is an integer 32-bit column
because architectural reasons we will be
transferring not only if the table has
and rose we're a transfer in not only
and x 4 bytes which is over interesting
draw an interesting column sorry but we
will be transferring and x 64 bytes ok
and 64 is it seems like a magic number
but actually it is what is called a
cache line so whenever you go to the
memory and you want to fetch one single
element the system will bring to you to
the CPU cache 64 bytes ok so that means
that we are try we are transmitting much
more
a lot of information to the CPU much
more information that we actually needs
so what what happens if our table is
stored column wise well if it is start
column wise if we are interested only in
this column the actual rate will be only
exactly the same amount of bytes that we
are interested in okay because if these
columns are stored sequentially in
memory the CPU will bring the next
elements of the column into the cache
and then we'll we'll do all the total
equity much more faster so white chunky
chunky means more difficulty okay handle
data so why bother well efficient it
isn't interesting because it allows for
efficient and large enough shrinking and
it allows for on flight compression oops
I think yeah I I cannot yeah I mixed the
presentation so I cannot I'll show you
why why honking is interesting but you
have to trust me and I will try to fix
the day slides later on sorry about that
okay and finally why compression so
compression just is interesting because
of two reasons basically the first one
is because more data can be stored in
the same amount of media for example if
you're you have a data set in memory and
you can cook if you can compress it
using a compressor and discuss like a 3
x 3 3 X compression ratio you can I
outcome of that is you can store three
times more data in your using the same
resources even memory or on disk and a
second thing is that the compression
can be used to if for example if your
data set is compressed in memory maybe
the time that it takes to transmit the
compressed data into the caches and the
compress it in the cash maybe this time
can be with can be made faster for then
just transmitting the original it I said
with a compressing into the cache if we
can achieve that the time for
transmitting and the compressing is less
than transmitting the original data set
then we can get better performance and
for that we need a very fast compressor
and block is one of these compressors
when for example here we can see that
block can be up to five times in this
case faster than a typical memory copy
then this is the way typical way to do
streaming analytics with because
basically it's at the bottom is the the
big because container that will be a few
because iterators and filters and they
can use blocking as well so you can
retrieve blocks of information not only
items and then you can use more
sophisticated weaponry on top of it like
I tell tools that has been described
this morning oppai tools or cycles
whatever so I have three minutes or 23
minutes ok so let me you let me show you
finally some benchmarks with real data
that I've been been playing with lately
and this data set is the movie length
data set you can find all the materials
especially the ipython notebook so you
can reproduce my results and if you get
better results than me please tell me
about it because I will love to hear
about it so the movie lens like I said
typically is just a collection of a
collection of different ratings that
people gave two different movies and in
there are 33 of those and i am i will be
using the largest one which is 10
million
prey teams here is the way typically
where you can use because in this case
you can see the pandas will be the CSV
files and then we hear a people's egos
on them this is the way home you are you
playing also data and here is the way
for you waiting and pandas containers
which is very close in fact so here we
have the size of data set in this case
pandas takes like 11 [ __ ] bite and a
half more or less and the big holes
container without compression it's
slightly longer like twenty percent
longer but if you if you use compression
you can see that we can reduce the size
up to less than 100 megabytes which is a
huge win in poor this case in particular
and then the query performance for big
four because which is interesting so for
the pandas query we see that the query
takes a little bit more than half a
second and for the big holes using
without compressing it's already faster
than pandas but if you using compression
you can see that you can even reduce the
time to query and this is because you
are transmitting less information into
disappears and the compressing the
information disappears and then there is
also the version for the disc because
because can be on memory or on disk and
even the virtually on this can be faster
than the pandas and upon the square so
this is the final takeaway message for
today so big data is tricky to manage so
my advice is too late for you to look
for optimal companions for your data so
spending some time choosing your
appropriate appropriate data container
can be a big time saver in the long run
so to summarize nowadays you should be
aware of the memory hierarchy for
getting good performance leverage your
existing memory efficient libraries
performing computing computations
optimally and you should use the
propagator containers for your different
use cases then some references and thank
you
okay thanks Francesca for that very
insightful talk we have time for about
three or four questions probably one
understood oh the memory works okay no
it is the system sorry I have to repeat
the question so the question was if the
prefetching has to be done manually okay
oh it's actually done by the battery
state automatically so the answer is
that it is the system who is in charge
to doing the profession for you yeah you
only have to I mean if you want to
upland to apply the blocking technique
you only have to do your algorithm your
avalons so that you are processing just
a block at a time and then the system
will be in charge of bringing this block
into the into the CPU cache and we'll do
the operation for you right our
questions so i have a question in fact
yeah can you say something about the
Nomex support in handles yeah I mean no
max pandas can use new mex prefer doing
the evaluation of a field of queries but
for example in this case pandas cannot
be enabled to use new mex just because
it is these things are represented as
objects in pandas okay so what becomes
does is strings are represented as as
new by strings Piron umpire strings and
no max has support for family no strings
no moon pie strings so this is one of
the reasons why even using no
compression because can be faster than
pandas pandas cannot be used new mex in
this in this case okay okay if there is
no more questions let's time franchise
once again
you
you